sin miedo a las represalias las mujeres
afganas continúan exigiendo al grupo
talibán que reabra en las escuelas para
niñas mayores de 11 años después de la
repentina decisión de los
fundamentalistas que el miércoles
impidieron las clases a las alumnas de
sexto grado en adelante hasta elaborar
un plan integral e islámico
pedimos a los dirigentes del emirato
islámico que abran las escuelas para
niñas en el plazo de una semana si las
escuelas siguen cerradas incluso después
de una semana las abriremos nosotras
mismas y organizaremos manifestaciones
en todo el país hasta que se cumplan
nuestras exigencias
de
activistas por los derechos de las
mujeres han vuelto a alzar la voz y
amenazan a los talibanes con iniciar una
ola de protestas si el grupo no respeta
los derechos fundamentales de las
menores afganas en afganistán menos del
30 por ciento de las adolescentes pueden
leer y escribir según los datos del
banco mundial de 2018
queremos dar a vermont marc soy en alfa
beta pero no quiero ver a mis hijas así
estábamos todos descontentos cuando
cerraron las escuelas mi hija mayor
todavía en casa estaba llorando porque
le dijeron que esperar el próximo
anuncio de los talibanes
se cree que el cambio de sentido de los
talibanes refleja divisiones entre la
línea dura y los más moderados la
activista paquistaní y premio nobel de
la paz también se pronunció al respecto
y al no al ningún siempre entendí que
debería ser una condición no negociable
para cualquier reconocimiento
diplomático de los talibanes creo en las
conversaciones de paz creo en el diálogo
pero también creo que al mismo tiempo no
deberían ser reconocidos si no reconocen
los derechos humanos de las mujeres y
las niñas 371 'la reina' less the human
rights of huelgas este domingo los
extremistas anunciaron la segregación
por sexos de los parques de la capital
kabul prohibiendo a los hombres y
mujeres compartir estos espacios
públicos